[MUSIC PLAYING]
XIAOCHEN ZHANG:
So Lu, maybe tell
us about your journey in
early career in corporate,
and why you make the
decision to jump.
LU LI: Yeah, so hi, everyone.
I'm so happy to be here.
Last time I was
here, actually, was
in my role as a mentor
for Google Launchpad.
So yeah, very
excited to be back.
To give you a little
bit of background
about my past and professional
life, as Xiaochen, I'm Chinese.
And when you grow up
as a Chinese child,
you have a lot of expectations,
you know, from your family
that you sort of need to
fulfill to have a good life
or to be deemed successful.
So my parents always
wanted me to go
either into business or into
law or into medicine, right?
And so I chose business.
And I did business
school in Germany.
So I was born in China, and
then grew up in Germany,
got all my education in
Germany, went to business school
in Germany, and
started with McKinsey
in Munich almost 10 years
ago, nine years ago.
Asian genes.
[LAUGHTER]
And yeah, I started
working with McKinsey,
then moved on to join P&G
and worked in Switzerland
in brand management
and marketing.
And I've done that for about
four or five years in total.
And then I sort of
jumped and, you know,
just kind of became
my own person,
if that makes sense, kind of
embarked on this path of being
an entrepreneur and
trying to find out
what I want to do on my own.
And the reason for that,
to answer the question,
actually, is I don't think you
ever actually leave a company.
I think you leave a manager.
Hmm?
Think about that.
And in my case, you
know, it was kind of--
you know, I had
difficulties with the boss
that I was reporting to.
I also saw that he had
difficulties with the boss
that he was reporting to.
So if you kind of think about
the whole sort of reporting
chain, it just doesn't
really work out.
And it was like, oh my
god, this is a dead end.
And you know, it was
not possible, basically,
for me to maneuver in any way
in that sort of situation.
And I just basically
had to leave the company
to kind of find something new.
And as I thought, OK, I
need to remove myself out
of this situation, do I want
to join another corporate?
Or do I take the opportunity
to do something on my own?
And that was five years ago.
And I decided to do
something on my own
because I'm one of these people
who think I can do things
better than other people.
And yeah, I embarked
on that journey.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG:
Yeah, do you ever
wish you could maybe
create it earlier on,
or this is exactly good
timing for you to do so?
LU LI: I think it
was the right time.
I don't think there's ever,
I suppose, the best time
to leave a job, right?
You just feel it.
I mean, you know, when
you are frustrated enough,
and in my case, you
know, you'll do it.
Or if there's a big enough
other opportunity that lures you
in, then you'll do it, right?
I think every decision
that people make,
then it's kind of like--
if it comes from the heart,
it's kind of like
you're fully behind it,
then it is the
right time for you.
And for me, it was
definitely the right time.
I don't think I should have
done it earlier or later.
So I don't regret that I sort
of jumped five years ago.
I think what I
would say, though,
is because I was
in Switzerland--
no, I was actually in
Germany as an expat,
and then I moved
back to Switzerland.
And I was not really part of
the entrepreneurial ecosystem,
because there was none.
I think, knowing
that, being in London
and having so many
things around you
I think is definitely
helpful to immerse yourself
even while you're employed
in these activities.
I mean, we've run a
lot of things, also,
over the weekends,
events and all of that.
So I think that's one thing
I wished I would have had.
But I didn't have
it at the time.
So there was no choice.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Cool.
And after you quit, do
you naturally directly go
to entrepreneurship, or you
take some time to figure out
what you want to do?
And how long did it take?
LU LI: I mean, I
left with the vision
to do something on my own.
I didn't know what
I wanted to do.
I just, I suppose,
wanted to do something
that leverages my
strength and do something
that I'm passionate
about and I love.
And I think that's
what a lot of people
think about when they
sort of quit a job.
And then it's
about actually sort
of finding out whether
the idea that you have
is a viable business, or
can be a viable business,
and is also a business that
you want to actually build,
because, you know, if you're
working for a big company,
you have all the infrastructure
that you can dream of, right?
I mean, buildings and food
and assistance and telephones
and all of these things that you
have to take care of yourself
when you work for
yourself, right?
And people find out that
you like certain things
or you are better at
certain things than others.
And so before I started
Blooming Founders,
I had two other companies,
which I ran by myself
almost as a one-woman show.
And I learned through
that process--
I did that for about three
years, two and 1/2 years--
that I don't want to build
a company that just has me
as one person, right?
Because obviously, you can
trade your time for money
and then you can just kind
of consult in a capacity.
And you know, you
can pay your rent,
you can pay your expenses,
and that's kind of it.
But I just realized by
doing that, after a while,
that I had the
ambition or just--
I wasn't satisfied myself.
So I wanted to build something
bigger, more sustainable,
with more impact.
And that I couldn't have
known in the beginning.
It's kind of, I think, if
you are taking the leap
and then trying to find
out what you want to do,
I think it's very, very
natural that you're
doing different things,
trying different projects,
and find out what works for you
and what doesn't work for you.
Yeah, so it takes time.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Good.
And how does a book
idea come along.
Before you answer, I just want
to ask our audience a question.
How many of you guys do
write handwriting letters
to anyone around the world?
Just hands up if
you still do that.
LU LI: Oh, nice.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: To
families, to friends.
Yeah, nice.
LU LI: How many people
keep a journal, actually?
How many people
write to themselves?
Uh-huh, a bit more.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: I wonder, do
they write to you English,
or in your mother tongue,
like, native language?
It's quite intimate to
write a letter to someone.
So how does an idea
come around for you?
LU LI: So the book idea is
one of the first projects
I released under my new
company, Blooming Founders.
I started completely
from scratch.
The idea was to kind of
build an infrastructure
for female founders, because
as I was out there doing stuff
on my own, I realized
that a lot of other women
are out there doing
stuff on their own.
And then if you're in
the startup ecosystem,
you see no women.
So you kind of like
trying to square up
what's happening here, right?
And it seems to me that
there's a lot of women around.
But you know, there's
no infrastructure
that they go to, apparently.
And I didn't know why
that was happening.
So I started running events,
bringing women together
that are entrepreneurial,
inviting female founders
as speakers and, you
know, sort of doing talks
and exactly what you are doing,
with 90% women in the audience.
And actually, I'm so glad that
we have a lot of guys in here.
I'm really, really glad,
because obviously, you know,
the title was "Dear
Female Founder."
So you know, wasn't
expecting this so, yay, guys.
Coming back to the story,
yeah, I started doing events.
And you know, at these
events, you obviously network
after the event.
And you find out over time
that there are no role models,
or very few role models that
women have in entrepreneurship,
that the media talks about
the typical sort of people
such as Elon Musk, such as Mark
Zuckerberg, such as Larry Page.
And all of these people
are all great people,
but they are not us.
It's just different, basically.
You know, it's not the same.
And this book came
about from my view
of, I think there's so many
amazing women out there,
because I invite them
to speak at my events,
that we need to
share more content.
And we also need to share
more authentic content.
Not me going out
and interviewing
people, which I could
have done, but I'm not
a trained journalist.
I don't even know what
to ask, basically.
I can answer questions.
So that's why I came up with
the idea of writing a letter,
because I think it's
quite a powerful tool.
And also, it digs out,
you know, tacit insights
from those entrepreneurs
that they probably
would have never been prompted
by a journalist, right?
Because who knows what's
in your head, right?
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Exactly.
Yeah.
LU LI: So that's the long
story to how this came about.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: And
when you're collecting
all the 66 different letters
from the female founders,
is there any particular
one impressed the most,
or something you never expected?
LU LI: Yeah, I got that
question asked a lot.
There are 66 letters
in that book,
so there is quite a few amazing
women that got featured.
And I have several favorites
for different reasons, I think.
People that are just super
practical and just kind
of, you know--
when you read this, you go,
oh my god, yes, of course.
I should do this, you know?
And then people that are
a bit more reflective.
And it takes a bit longer
to process, basically.
And sometimes, I mean,
even I had to read--
I mean, I had to read, because
I edited the whole thing,
but I had to read
letters several times
to understand what's behind.
And so yes, I mean, I do
have my favorite letters,
for different reasons, I think.
And I mean, I can probably
say, the first one of each--
so I have three larger
sections in the book.
Probably the first
one that I put
was kind of one
of the favorites.
And the last one is quite
powerful as well, actually.
Yeah.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Cool.
Can't wait to read
the whole book.
I think you guys are
probably thinking the same.
And when you founded
your business,
do you find this advice gave
you good reason to [INAUDIBLE]
have you ever experienced some
of the failures or hard time?
And how do you cope with that?
LU LI: Yeah, I think that is
the business of reality, right?
I mean, if anybody thinks
that when you start off
your own business, it's going
to be A to B, like, forget it.
It's not going to happen.
I mean, there's
naturally up and downs.
And then, I mean, I
think sort of reading
all of these
articles and letters,
I think there's just a lot of
things that are just very real.
I think just one of the things--
I mean, it just springs to mind,
but don't work with idiots.
Yeah.
I mean, nobody tells you that,
but don't work with idiots.
Very simple.
And I say it's simple,
but it's actually not,
because sometimes you
are in a situation where
you have to work with people
that you actually don't like,
for example.
And then it can drag a lot of
energy and time out of you.
And sometimes, you
know, the boldest move
you can actually
make is actually
stop working with these
people, even if you
have to say no to money, right?
And cash flow is obviously
important, always,
but sometimes it's
just very liberating
not to work with certain people.
And I know that
from the community--
and obviously I've produced the
book for the Blooming Founders
community--
I know that some people have
it next to their bedside table.
And then when they have a
shitty day, then, you know-- oh,
can I swear, actually?
I don't know.
Beep.
When they have a bad
day, they would sort of
dip into the book.
And then they would sort
of be motivated again,
et cetera, et cetera, because,
you know, life happens.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: That's true.
So when you were on your
entrepreneur journey
did you have mentors?
Do you have good
mentor, bad mentor,
and how do you know at that
time that's bad advice for you?
How do you know it?
LU LI: I believe
if you don't know,
I think it's good to just listen
to a lot of different opinions.
And then you have
to just make up
your mind yourself,
basically, of what
you listen to and just
align with your gut.
Like, who do you
trust most, right?
You know, because most
of the time, you ask--
I mean, don't
listen to people who
tell you something
and you actually
find out they have never
done it themselves, right?
I mean, we know too
many of those people.
And there's a lot of
mentors and advisors,
also, in the startup
world that have never
done anything themselves.
But then they, you
know, are going around
and advising people.
And so that, be careful about.
And over time, I think the
good mentors and advisors,
they would actually sort
of follow up with you,
because they like you and they
really want to support you.
So with most of my
current mentors,
I wouldn't even call them
mentors, because we almost
became friends, right?
I mean, I have
everyone on WhatsApp,
and if I have any
questions, basically,
I just ping them a message.
And then, you know,
I see what they say.
And then I think, oh, this makes
sense, this doesn't make sense.
And then I just move on.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Cool.
I think I read a research or
another interview you did.
In UK, there's around 75%
of the female founders,
they are also solo founders,
so they don't have co-founder,
and own by themselves.
What do you think can be
done to change the reality?
Or what caused that, and
what things we can do?
LU LI: So I think the reasons
behind is probably not
that easy to explain.
I mean, there's
multitudes of things.
There's research, for
example, that women
in business, and in
general, have a smaller
network but a deeper network.
And men in business
have a wider network
and more shallow
network, which means
that they know more people.
And then societally,
also, men tend
to not shy away from
just picking up the phone
and call up a mate
to ask him a favor
or to ask him to do something.
Whereas women tend not to do
that, basically, because they
are aware it's risky
and they don't really
want to drag another
friend into the whole thing
before they are 100% certain
it's perfect and it's totally,
you know, safe to do, which
obviously it never is.
And yeah, so I think a lot
of women in the community,
in Blooming Founders,
you know, are solo
founders because they choose
that path of [? XY, ?]
that reason.
Could be because
they were frustrated
in their previous
job, because they're
really passionate about
this idea that they have,
but at that time when
they had the idea,
there was nobody else around
that was similarly passionate
or that they knew
for long enough
to kind of be a co-founder.
But then people venture
out, and then they
try to find the
co-founding team.
And that [INAUDIBLE] you know,
becomes really difficult as
well, because you don't,
obviously, know the people.
And then people might
take advantage of you
and all of these things.
So I think it's a
multitude of reasons
why women tend to build
businesses on their own.
Said this, though,
I mean, luckily
we still have women
founding teams,
you know, mixed teams as well,
that build great businesses.
But I think the overall
sort of landscape
is unfortunately still that way.
And I hope through you
know, the work that we do--
so we recently opened
a physical space,
a physical work and event
space called Bloom's London.
It's a co-working space slash
event space slash members club.
And I think the
members club element
comes through bringing the
community together, right,
connecting you with
other women that
do similar things in business,
but have different businesses.
And you can collaborate.
And then you can form
teams that might not
be sitting under one
company, but at least are
sort of associated in a way, so
you're not working on your own.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: So maybe
slightly outside the topic--
you know, in corporate,
we're always talking
about work-life balance.
We have yoga.
We have [INAUDIBLE]
here, as you know.
Once you become
entrepreneur, and you
used to be in this environment,
how do you adjust yourself,
and how do keep the balance?
LU LI: I think balance--
it's an interesting
question, actually.
I think balance is
a personal choice.
I think everybody needs to get
to know their own bodies better
and, you know, understand,
are you a morning person?
Are you a night person?
What person are you?
Are you normal, regular
working hours person?
And what do you need in
your life, basically, right?
So when I left
corporate, what I've done
is actually I've
wiped out my schedule,
like 9:00 to 5:00 or whatever,
and also Monday through Friday,
because I had seven
days in the week.
And I'm not sure if--
you probably know this--
I'm not sure what it was.
But you know, there's a
story about this professor
in a university.
And he comes up with these
two vases and stones and sand.
And then he talks to
his students about--
I think it's about time
management or something.
And he puts in the stones
in the vase, and then--
sorry, the sand into the vase,
and then the stones and it
doesn't fit, basically.
and it overflows.
And then he puts
the stones first,
and then the sand around it.
And then everything
fits perfectly.
And I think there was the
analogy around, you know,
making sure you have
the priorities in check
and, you know, your
ducks in a row.
But I think that's what
I have pretty much done
with my schedule, with my time.
So I wiped everything out.
And I said, OK, I need to
sleep, like, seven hours a day.
So where do I plug that in?
I actually tend to sleep between
1:00 and 8:00, for example.
And I work the best, actually,
between 10:00 and 1:00,
because that's
like my quiet time.
I plotted that in.
Then, you know, friends.
I see them for brunch
or drinks or whatever.
I need to call my mom.
You know, all of these
things, basically.
But somehow,
actually, I realized
I had a really simple life.
So I don't have that
many stones to put in.
As a result, the rest,
basically, was sand for me.
And my business is
sand, basically, right?
It's kind of everything else
that I create in my life.
And that's my definition
of work-life balance,
because if there's another
stone coming, I mean,
I would basically sort of
make that stone work somehow
and just remove the
sand a little bit.
Yeah.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: That's good.
LU LI: Maybe that helps.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Yeah.
I'll ask one more question.
And I'll open up to the floor.
The Googlers are really
good with questions.
Just be prepared.
So what advice would you
give to founders out there?
It doesn't matter male, female.
What would you say to them?
LU LI: I would actually
say, the advice
that you find in this book is
applicable to everybody, right?
I mean, it just comes
from a female perspective
because that person
happens to be a woman.
But I think my general
advice is to do it,
to explore whether
entrepreneurship is for you.
There's literally
nothing to lose.
I mean, if you think--
I mean, maybe you
lose a bit of money.
Fine.
I mean, you can
join another company
and earn money again, right?
But you know, the
time is not lost,
because you learn so much.
And it's so different, actually,
to how corporate life works.
And you also get to
know yourself, actually,
a lot better.
So I think entrepreneurship
is a really good way
for personal development.
And, you know, some
people succeed.
Great.
Some people don't.
But then they realize,
actually, you know,
I don't have to
build a business.
I'm actually much more happier--
because sometimes you
don't know what you have
until you actually get rid of it
and lose it, basically, right?
And some people, actually,
are very happy back in the job
and still do what they did
on the side, as a hobby,
basically.
But then at least you know.
You feel a lot more comfortable
and at ease that, you know,
this is how I want to
design my life now, right?
I mean, it's not a constant
state, I would say.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, great.
So now I'll open
up to the floor.
If you have questions,
just raise your hand
and we'll give you a microphone.
So we'll start from there.
AUDIENCE: Tell me
about the process
of writing the book, in terms of
selecting the founders, how you
pitch it, how you convince them
to separate a time to write
this really intimate letter.
Do you give them a deadline?
Did you have to do much chasing?
Tell us a bit more about that.
LU LI: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it took me about nine
months from having the idea
to actually holding
the book in my hand.
So it's self-published
through Amazon.
Everybody can
self-publish a book.
And it took me, in
total, nine months.
And I started with
the women that I
knew, that I have invited
to speak at my events.
And I think the criteria was
that they had to be-- you know,
they must have achieved
something interesting,
basically, and significant.
So I had, like, they had to
be in business for at least
three years, and ideally,
this many employees
or raised that much
funding or have
generated this much revenue.
So all of the 66,
all together, they've
generated a billion
dollars in revenue,
and some obviously more
than others, but, you know.
And yeah, I leveraged
my own personal network.
Then I have asked
them, basically,
to kind of refer
me to other women,
because it's a sort of small
group of [INAUDIBLE] so then
people tend to
know other people.
I have also reached out
through the Google network,
like the accelerator
networks, Startup Weekend.
I volunteer for Startup Weekend.
I organize Startup Weekends.
And Startup Weekend
is around the globe.
And that I utilized after
I have pretty much gotten,
like, 20 people in
and around London
and the US, which are pretty
much the first people you get
because the density is there.
But I really wanted to
have a global perspective.
So you have people from New
Zealand, China, and Colombia
and Mexico, and things.
So for that I had to sort
of talk to other networks.
And Startup Weekend
is an amazing network.
You know, everybody's so helpful
and helping you to connect.
And also, my business
school friends,
because they are everywhere
in the world now, from
Dubai to Indonesia to everyone.
So I'd be like, hi, you know.
And so that's how
I've reached out.
I also tried LinkedIn.
I did LinkedIn
connections and messages.
That was the least effective.
But I got a couple through that.
Yeah.
And how I approached
them was actually--
I actually just wrote a letter
myself as an example, right?
And I gave them quite specific,
I suppose, directions.
So it started with "Dear
Female Founder," because that's
the title of the book.
And everything started
with "Dear Female Founder."
It has to be between
800 and 1,500 words.
So it also communicates,
it's not too long.
You know, you're
not asking to write
a book, but just a letter.
And basically, just
think about, if you
were to sit down and write
a letter, what would you
advise to your younger self
or your best friend who
is starting a business,
or the future generation
of female founders, right?
And I think that idea
just resonated a lot
with the people
that contributed,
that everybody was
just so happy to do it.
And they were like, oh my god,
I always wanted to do that.
It's good that you're
giving me the chance.
And I got, actually,
a lot of gratitude
back from people, because
people were like, actually,
you know, thank
you for helping me
to find my voice and my
story and to tell my story,
because I've never
done that before,
because I was never
asked, because that comes
to the original problem, because
they were never asked, right?
So yes, I think somehow
the idea just resonated.
Pretty much everybody
had a positive response.
Probably half the
people I've contacted--
I've contacted
around 150 people--
said it's lovely, I
would love to contribute,
but I'm so super busy that
I just don't have time.
But let me know when it's out,
and I would love to support
and spreading the
word or something.
Yeah.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Cool.
So just go around.
Did they also post it to you,
like write it and stamp it?
LU LI: No, no, no.
Oh, yeah, Google Docs, guys.
So yeah, no, to be honest,
the actual-- my work
was really just
project management,
because it was just, you know,
you create your hit list,
you contact them, you
see what they say.
There's everything in
Excel or Google Sheets.
And then literally,
I would just ask
people to send me a Google Doc.
And then I would edit it in
the Google Doc with them.
And every letter probably
had, you know, between three
to five rounds of feedback.
And that's it, right?
You sign off.
That's the text.
You copy it further.
And that's that.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: That's good.
Good to know.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thanks for sharing your story.
So you mentioned
that the letters
are from sort of a global base.
You spoke to people
and had contributions
from all over the world.
What proportion of
the letters were
from the US versus Europe
versus Asia, in general?
And did you notice any
trends, like themes
of different types of
challenges that people faced
in North America versus
what perhaps they faced here
or in APAC?
LU LI: So I think around--
I forgot the numbers,
to be honest,
but around 20 people are
actually from the UK.
Another 15 or so
are from the US.
So probably half of the
book is kind of UK, US.
And then the rest is kind of
like across the globe, right?
And at some point,
I was just literally
keen on having somebody in
Africa, for example, right?
Yeah, and I think in terms
of the advice that people--
I mean, I also had entrepreneurs
that also, for example, did
stuff in Sierra Leone but
were actually Americans,
for example.
So it's a bit-- you know.
But I think in
terms of advice, I
think it really depends
more on the type of business
and the industry that they were
in than the actual country.
I do see, in the
Asian sort of sphere,
there is more cultural
expectations around the topic
of entrepreneurship,
because it's not something
that women do, to be honest.
And it's funny, because I think
the girl from Latin America--
well, the lady, actually.
She's a scientist.
She does heavy,
heavy science stuff.
She kind of was
interesting, because she's
doing this super serious
thing, and then her letter
was kind of really bubbly.
So that's where I felt,
you know, in the way
that she was writing that the
Latin American sort of flavor
came out a little bit.
But that's just kind of
from an editing perspective.
From a content
perspective, I would
say I was surprised to see
that probably only like 5%
to maximum 10% of what
people talk about is actually
genderized, is
actually sort of about,
oh, as a female
founder, da da da da.
Like, most of the things are
really just super applicable
across everything.
And I found that
quite interesting,
because I didn't give them
a more specific brief than I
shared with you just now.
And people were not,
you know, oh my god, I'm
a female founder, I'm so
discriminated, and, you know,
the world is so
horrible, et cetera.
I mean, you obviously have
that, but in the grand scheme
of things, I think
probably also people just
don't want to share that back
to the future generation, right?
I think we want to
be more positive
about entrepreneurship.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: As you've
mentioned, that as women, we
don't have as many role
models in terms of CEOs
that are females out there.
I was just wondering if
there were any common topics
in the book and the
letters about women
feeling a bit like
the imposter syndrome.
In Google, sometimes
I talk about, oh, I'm
not sure if I should be here
or if I deserve to be here.
So I was just wondering,
with women being CEOs,
if they talked about
anything about,
I cannot believe I'm a
CEO, or things like that.
LU LI: Yeah, they did.
They do.
And I think what did come out--
I think what makes a
difference that women
wrote those letters is
a little bit of that,
but a lot about taking care
of yourself kind of thing
and being true to
yourself and not
trying to do something just
because the rest of the world
wants you to do it, right?
So for example, I mean, a
typical startup acceleration
phase is you start a startup,
you go through an accelerator,
you get your seed funding,
you get your series A and B
and so forth, right?
And it requires a
certain type of business
to do that and actually perform
against all of these metrics.
But it might not be
the best business.
And it might not be the
best business for you,
as well, right?
So people pivot.
And then sometimes it's
kind of like, you know,
am I doing the wrong
thing, of having graduated
from a [? Texas ?] accelerator,
for example, and now pivoting
into an agency,
for example, that
might be super
profitable because we're
really good at what we're doing,
but isn't the high-growth tech
business that people
thought that we
were doing in the beginning.
And I think letting go and sort
of that type of attachment,
you can read a little
bit through the book.
And also, then,
attached to that--
it's very stressful, obviously,
to just be OK with yourself,
to say OK, you know,
I am in that game,
or I am in a different
game, and I'm
totally fine with being
in a different game.
And to the imposter
syndrome thing,
so that's actually in the
first letter, written by a lady
called Alex, Alexandra
Depledge from Hassle.com.
She exited Hassle
a couple years ago,
and now she's building
her second startup,
called Buildpath.
And one of her tips
for that is when
you sort of have an
important meeting,
an important presentation,
you go to the bathroom,
you look into the
mirror, and you say,
I am the shit, to yourself.
And then you go back out.
And then it's all good.
So things like that, you know?
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Cool.
Over there.
AUDIENCE: So what is the
next step for you from here?
LU LI: So you know what?
The book was
literally something--
I mean, I didn't have any
motives behind the book,
to be honest, right?
I mean, I published it because
I felt the content was needed.
And then I was engaging with
the community at the time.
So for me, I'm obviously super
happy to promote the book
all the time, because I think
it's valuable content to share.
But you know, I'm not
[INAUDIBLE],, basically.
There's no gigantic
other thing that is
kind of coming behind the book.
It's literally just kind of
for the universe, really.
And so my businesses is around
building this infrastructure
for female founders, right?
And the book is
obviously one element.
It's one product
that you can get.
And the other product, the
thing that I want to scale,
is this online-to-offline
sort of infrastructure
that includes the
online community, where
you can make connections
and share knowledge
and experiences, plus then
sort of seeing everybody
in real life in those co-working
spaces that I'm creating.
So that's kind of the business
that I'm looking to build.
And at the moment, we have
the first one in Old Street.
And we're looking
to kind of then
grow that and open more
spaces in West London.
I'm actually thinking about
Bali, because why not?
Who doesn't want to
work in Bali, right?
And other locations, yeah.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG:
We're going to do
one more question, and then--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Lu.
Thank you for joining.
This is truly amazing, something
that I would dream to publish,
but I'm glad you beat me to it.
The question I have
for you is, were
there anyone, or any
founders, that you reached out
to where you thought
they might never respond,
and when they did, you
were kind of nervous
or, like, oh my god,
they actually responded?
Like a Sheryl Sandberg, or--
LU LI: Yeah, I tried to
reach out to Sheryl Sandberg,
but didn't get far
enough, I suppose.
I don't know.
It's a difficult question to
answer, because I personally,
honestly think that every woman
who has achieved something
almost has a moral
obligation to do that.
So therefore, you
know, I think that when
people responded positively,
it was like, yes, you get it.
Awesome.
Let's do this.
Right?
Like, I wasn't being
like, oh my gosh,
she accepted, and
this is so amazing.
You know, it's fine.
Yeah, because in
that way, I mean,
I felt a bit entitled,
if that makes sense.
In a non sort of
like, oh, you know,
I think you must do
this kind of thing.
But I actually genuinely
think that, you know,
successful people have
a moral obligation
to share their knowledge
with the future generation.
So I was generally
happy that they
got it and they were
supporting me on that journey.
And I think I was also kind of--
I think what I was
surprised about is actually
the surrounding support, right?
One thing I forgot to
mention is actually,
I also had a nomination process
to find interesting women.
And a lot of people actually
used that, actually,
because sometimes you don't
know the women yourself,
but their previous PA or
their marketing manager
is now a female founder herself.
And then she knows me,
so she would sort of
suggest her previous
boss, and stuff like that.
So that, I actually
felt, was really nice.
That got me and was like,
oh, this is really exciting.
I didn't know you were doing--
so yeah.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Cool.
Great.
So thank you, Lu Li for
sharing the experience--
LU LI: Thank you.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: --and book.
And thank you,
everyone, for coming
and all the good questions.
I hope you guys enjoy the book.
And feel free to maybe ask Lu Li
afterwards for a few questions,
sign the book if you want.
So yeah, see you guys next time.
Thank you so much.
LU LI: Thank you.
XIAOCHEN ZHANG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]